i want to talk about the other side of
this so uh we're reading a story from a
business insider it's very critical of
this convention of states where you
basically have
conservative leaning states are slowly
getting closer and closer to calling an
article 5 convention so just for those
who missed the segment but on the other
side of this you have the more liberal
leaning states getting closer and closer
to a a national popular vote coalition
which would undermine the electoral
college and in my opinion
literally just be
telling the world like the one that
happens
hey we want to do a civil war here it's
basically what you're saying if you do
this i think it's a terrible idea a
convention of states is like well
they'll propose some some amendments
maybe they can happen but i mean if you
need 38 states to ratify anyway that
could happen through the congress anyway
i'd imagine a convention of states being
called opens a conversation undermining
electoral college through states
agreeing with each other just instantly
ends the republic uh electoral process
for for the president it it
fundamentally changes how we elect the
president and and
makes the flyover states
real flyover states they become ignored
because they uh they don't have the they
don't that's not where the votes are the
presidential campaigns will be run
in california texas florida and new york
that's where that's where it will be
decided and it's not just that though um
and that's by the way every every
president will be beholding to these big
blue population centers because that's
where the people live
even in red states yes realize this yeah
so uh west virginia for instance yeah
when you go to the cities in west
virginia they're still more liberal
leaning and the surprising thing is to
me you know in the second most trump
supporting state you can go to a city
and see the rainbow flags there's uh
areas of virginia rural virginia as well
when you're out in the farmland when
you're out in the rural areas and the
houses are few and far between what do
you see you see trump signs everywhere
we got one big sign over here is a
gigantic sign that says the swamp is 40
miles that way it's hilarious and then
you you go into a town of 20 30 000
people still the city and you see the
blm flags so what's going to happen then
is you got a politician with only so
much money we go national popular vote
it's going to be
even in west virginia the politicians
are going to be saying things to pander
liberals because you got 20 000 votes i
can go here do a rally get all of them
or i can
go to farms
come on that's too difficult it's too
far away
so this is just i think this is the
inversion of it you know what we see the
convention of states this is a move
being being made by the democrat
liberal-leaning states which i think you
centralize power right
yeah as mark said i mean
all you have to understand about the
left it's all about power everything
they want to do everything it the the
motive behind it is to accumulate power
and centralize it into the elites who
they believe best know how to run
everything
so what do you do man i mean if if
you've got
half the country moving towards this
half the country moving towards a a
convention of states you've got a
pulling away in opposite directions the
culture's already fractured people have
already been talking about civil war
long before i ever brought it up i think
the convention of states is actually the
antidote to the to the to a civil war i
think you're right i think this country
is increasingly divided increasingly
distrustful of the other side not just
distrustful
you're about right hatred of the other
side they they believe that they have
bad motives and want to hurt them and
harm them
that is that is a that is a uh
headed toward very ugly things and what
mark has been able to do
is take a lot of people who maybe feel
that would probably not maybe they do
feel that way and channel them into
something that the founders provided as
the emergency escape clause you know
the problem with national popular vote
from a marketing perspective you said
like the easy thing sells right take
away your vote to vote for your senator
that sounds bad you're not going to
repeal the 17th amendment national
popular vote when you say to people
what's ridiculous somebody wins the
popular vote for president and then
they're not president that's a pretty
good marketing tool in my opinion much
harder to counter to explain to people
why that doesn't work so i think it's a
very dangerous movement i agree with
rick i agree with you i think we are
headed towards a civil war i think the
country is decoupling where i differ
with a lot of people is i think it's
awesome and the reason i think it's
awesome is because this is how our
country has always been we have some
fantasy that we've been some unified
country like right before the american
revolution when the colonies hated each
other and called each other blasphemers
and we're ready to go to no it was that
way after the revolution we get together
and we decide we're going to form a
government we hate each other so much we
form the articles of confederation gives
the federal government no power because
the colonies and then the states don't
trust each other we come out of that
there's a fantasy we all love each other
yeah so much so in the 1860s we have a
civil war and we force a union 80 years
later right right after the civil war we
really liked it yeah exactly everybody
that's when things were calm and
peaceful and it's crazy never was it uh
1876 was it the election was decided by
a committee yes and so initiation so
we've never actually as a country liked
each other very much except and this and
this is what we we forget is it was
really after world war ii correct that's
the only time if you look at america
where there was a consensus and it's
because we had just gone through two uh
two world wars and a great depression
and people were just tired of
fighting and wanted to be at home with
their family and raise children and not
work i mean it was an idyllic time but
it would everyone thinks oh that was
america no
no america was never like this was it a
beautiful time it was a great time you
could say a lot of great things about
about about the 50s and 60s but it
didn't take long for us to say well you
know that look there's
agitating
against injustice that's always been the
american way and by the way in many
cases and certainly in the case of the
60s the civil rights movement it was a
great movement
we've always been a country that never
just wanted everybody to get along
because we're always agitating
for something better and unfortunately
the ideology behind what's better since
the 1960s since after the civil rights
movement has been destructive because
it's been based on relativism socialism
marxism and trying to bring that to this
country and now it's up to us
to
to to fight back this culture war and
and the founders gave us the opportunity
to do it it's about truth
so
critical race theory for instance
you know i i i it's it's well it's an
ideology right and it's it's also a lie
it's twisted and uh you know i love
when i get challenged by you know i'll
be on facebook because i waste time on
facebook talk about multiple monitors
and i'm reading the news and i had
someone uh post about critical race
theory and saying republicans you know
they're crazy and they don't want you to
you know learn history about racism or
whatever
and so i quoted i posted saying
the meme was like it was a picture of
the the people getting the milkshakes
pouring on them
and then i just said something like
you know you
using these people for your political
ideology blah blah and then someone said
what is critical race theory to me so i
said oh you'd love to know let me tell
you because i do know critical race
theory is a derivative of critical
theory marxist ideology the idea that
there are is an oppressor in a pressed
class kimberly crenshaw wrote in her
book because i read this
i i read the chapter outlining the the
thesis the basis
that marx did not understand the the
racial tensions that exist in the united
states therefore the idea of
class oppression didn't work and you
needed race racial understanding thus a
critical race theory and then i wanted
to quote derek bell who argued for
segregation he i think he he was it he
plussy versus ferguson was a separate
but equal he argued in favor of it
saying the overturning of this in in
brown beef and brown be the board of
education were mistakes and i'm like
don't come to me trying to use the civil
rights movement to justify your ideology
when your ideology is rooted in
overturning the civil rights movement
but these people don't know that they
don't read these things
they never actually read where critical
race theory comes from they follow the
the lies from the corporate press
and so we're not up against any any you
know there's the truth
the truth will set you free but these
people don't want to hear it they're in
tribes they get their marching orders
from whatever the tv tells them to do
and they claim that's not them they
claim it's the other side and that's why
it's important for you to speak that's
why important for all of us to go out
and not be afraid what what's happening
in america until recently i give donald
trump a lot of credit for this
because he
exposed the national media for the
partisans that they were and he did so
by just
you know punching them in the nose and
getting them ticked off enough that they
dropped any pretense of being fair and
and and wanting to be journalists and
they revealed who they really are
all of us have seen it and we've we look
i was in politics for
been in politics for 40 years
and for 30 of those years
republican politicians would stand up to
the media on occasion but it we didn't
we didn't we didn't call them out for
who they were we knew who they were we
understood
who that 97 percent of the washington
press corps voted for democrats but we
always tried to you know the idea was
well you don't get into an argument with
someone who prints uh you know print
advising buy zinc by the barrel and so
that was the cradle of the republican
conservative movement which is don't
fight against the media because they'll
crush you and for one who did and got
crushed i was used as an example look
you don't don't stand up and and and
speak the truth because the the left
will crush you
now they can't crush us as much anymore
because of avenues like this and other
avenues and and we have an obligation to
use these avenues in spite of the
limitations that facebook and twitter
and youtube put on those to continue to
fight that battle and do it smartly well
you you were on cnn for a short while
what five years well oh so a little bit
not a short one not a short while my
life not a short while wow so so what
happened with that i mean to to be
critical of the media but to be in the
machine i mean
uh you know
i'll put it this way he's like i don't
know what i can talk about
i can talk about it like cnn was a uh
was an interesting i loved working in
cnn because i was generally speaking the
only person in on a show or on a panel
that had my point of view
and i knew that the vast majority of
almost all of the cnn audience didn't
agree with me
and so i i saw an opportunity to talk to
people about what conservatism was
uh
because they didn't hear it and so and
and so i had i had
i felt like i had to be better than
everybody else on the panel and i
they could scream at me but if i scream
back at them
then i'm gonna lose that audience out
there because i'm what they portray me
as yeah so it made me be
my wife said calmer
and and more thoughtful
no i didn't vary from the didn't back
away from anything i believed but i
tried to make sure that i was
communicating it's not what you say but
it's what people hear right right and so
i was trying to say it in a way that
people so for me it was a great
opportunity to to to make arguments to
people and cnn
when they put me on
gave me the opportunity to say whatever
i want so i have no complaints about it
i can complain that they didn't put me
on the shows as much as i would have
liked to have been but that's that's
that's the way it goes having said that
i got fired
cancelled because i made a comment that
uh the united states of america i was i
was giving a speech to a group of young
conservatives
about the founding of a country and i
made the comment that we were blessed in
this country to
have founding documents where we really
didn't have a country before this
country that unlike france which had
multiple governments and kings and
history here in america this was a brand
new country we started from a clean
slate and i said the native americans
were uh you know were here but there was
no country and that they had no they had
no impact on the on the uh on the uh on
the constitution and the culture and
that got me canceled you they canceled
me i saw a meme that's been going around
and it's uh you know you ever see the
meme where it's like what women would do
with the time machine what men would do
with the time machine
so
there's a bunch of them where it's like
one of my favorites is
the it's like what a woman would do the
time machine the young woman says i'm
your i'm your granddaughter and the
other young woman says wow from the
future then it says what men would do
and there's one of my favorite is
there's a guy with full tactical gear
and he's got guns and there's like a
world war one soldier and he says
grandfather come with me we're going to
jekyll island trust me just the
formation of the fed
so there was one i saw where
it's uh they're handing guns to native
americans and they're saying take these
because they're coming and they'll
destroy you and destroy your lands and
then all these you know leftists are
like you're like yeah
i just might respond to them my question
is do you know anything about the native
american tribes and what it was like
here because i'm not in any way
justifying the the history of
colonialism but i think you need to
point out if you went to a native
american tribe and handed them you know
m16s they would just go and massacre
their warring tribes this idea that all
the native americans were like unified
and it's like oh the evil white settlers
are coming to kill us we'll stop them
it's not not the case it would be like
if you said if we went to europe and
gave them laser guns and fighter jets
it's like yeah they go to war and they
kill each other whenever you give
weapons to uh you know advanced weaponry
to a society that doesn't have it they
will use it to empower themselves
but of course that's called human nature
that is truth and reality so when you
talk about the history of the americas
you had nomadic tribes you had some
tribal governments we did learn from and
adopt some of their principles it's
really it's really amazing history quite
in fact and then you look at like the
aztec empire and the brutal human
sacrifices and how they oppressed and
enslaved local tribes and it's like it's
not some utopian world but these people
believe in this woke psychotic narrative
where it's just like
whiteness
literally from europe or whatever they
want to call it is bad and wrong and
that means anyone else is good where in
human history have there not been
warring
people trying to control territory
different groups of people who have it
read the bible i mean
you look at the hebrews and the and the
philistines and and the moabites and
it's throughout the course of human
history there have been wars conquering
for land and the idea that
that
that is somehow should should not have
happened in this country that somehow
that america is
again it's it's it's not it's a for me
it's a dystopian view of of of how
the world and throughout history has
worked well so you said a moment ago
that you were
correct if i'm wrong you were saying you
think civil war what you were excited
for
no i'm excited for the division and the
reason i'm excited for it is because
like if you go back to the
constitutional convention the men in
that convention are screaming and
yelling at each other they're accusing
each other of all kinds of horrible
stuff it's the north versus the south
big states versus small states there are
commercial interests that are fighting
against each other in convention we look
back and we've got some weird fantasy
that these all guys sat around had a
couple of pints of ale and came up with
this beautiful document the document is
a result of that distrust that dislike
that hatred this is where federalism is
born because it's a system designed for
people who say look i don't really like
you i don't trust you you're going to
infringe on my interest so what we're
going to do is we know there's an
existential threat you've got england
you've got spain france is actually an
erstwhile ally they're a threat so we
got to band together for a few limited
things i still don't like you but i'm
going to band together in a federal
government with you
that's the solution for right now
because the reality is look people in
the south if you're in alabama you don't
really like people in new york generally
speaking yeah you could travel to those
places you'll steer still hear all the
same regional prejudices they have
always existed they always will so this
is a chance for us to say well how could
we live together is there any way we can
live together and the answer is yeah the
founders the framers told us have a
federal system where i say you know what
you can do what you want to do if i
don't like it i'm going to go live in
new york i think the challenge is uh i
don't think
when we talk about the left and the
right the left having the you know the
rule and not the exception the right is
exception not the rule i don't know if
there there's an acceptable compromise i
mean these are people who uh
cost
ended up res uh committed property
damage rioting and and murderous acts in
2020 and the politicians supported them
outright i mean kamala harris was was
funding their bail 13 joe biden staffers
i believe it was 13 uh
contributed to the bail of these
individuals who are committing these
crimes
i mean i don't know if there's a
solution even through a convention of
states because i feel like even if you
get the convention of states you deal
with the power of the federal government
these people still exist they still have
their their uh tribal culture and and
bloodlust or whatever you want to call
it
so i i feel like
a convention of states is good to
address the problems of the federal
government but i feel like it would it
would be a catalyst for a lot of these
far-left extremists and their cohorts in
government who are going to lose power
because of it and then it just triggers
conflict it just ignites it i would say
two things number one the most important
reason for convention of states is to
limit the power of the federal
government to force
cultural marxism and and and and mark
economic marxism on the entire country
so if we can stop them
from imposing try to to to
generally increase the power of the
federal government to the point where
they can impose that on the rest of the
country which will cause
i believe
if it continues on there will be
conflict there's no question there'll be
conflict uh the op the alternative is a
convention of states to propose
amendments that will limit the power of
the federal government or even just
having the convention
think about having the convention and
the states rising up and saying you know
we're going to check you that in of
itself may limit some of what the
federal government
attempts to do or the left tries to do
because they know now there's a viable
option for the states to push back right
and that it happened nothing horrible
happened maybe a couple of amendments
passed but now that it's happened once
it's a lot easier to have again the the
the the the the idea that
we're going to eliminate the left and
and their grab for power that's not
going to happen but it's going to be
isolated in the states of california and
others and we'll see the destruction
that is wrought in those states as we're
seeing it now and so what are what's
happening people are leaving those
states thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there